[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video i'm going to be discussing
none other than gilderoy lockhart
order of merlin third class honorary
member of the dark force defense league
hogwarts defense against the dark arts
professor and five-time winner of witch
weekly's most charming smile award
but let's not talk about his smile he
didn't get rid of the band and banshee
by smiling at her
more specifically i'm going to be
discussing what exactly happened to
lockhart
after the events of the chamber of
secrets so what's the deal
where did he go gilderoy lockhart was a
british half-blood wizard
born in the year 1964 to a witch mother
and muggle father
his parents had two other children two
girls but lockhart proved to be the only
one that was magical
which whether she would admit it or not
made him his mother's favorite child
lockhart was a clever good-looking boy
and when he realized quite early on that
he was magical
it only went to his head and inflated
his already massive ego
even further in 1975 lockhart began
attending hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry
when he first walked through the doors
of the school he was met with
disappointment
as he came to the crushing realization
that at his school for witches and
wizards
he was just another magical young boy in
the muggle world
gilderoy was exceptional but here he
didn't stand out
and that's all he ever longed for it's
been expressed that as a young boy
lockhart did possess slightly above
average abilities
but nothing particularly noteworthy and
his lack of attention only fueled the
fire inside of him
to be successful in 1982 lockhart
finally graduated from hogwarts
and it was at this point in time that he
began traveling all around the world
shortly after graduating lockhart began
to build prominence as an author
telling his readers tales of his heroism
and illustrious magical ability
he was genuinely famous he was a dark
wizard catcher
a dragon tamer a troll conqueror if
there's a dark and powerful presence in
the world
lockhart had vanquished it all by
himself the catch
only he was there to witness it after
each and every time that lockhart
traveled he would return home with a new
book
filled with self-promotion heroism and
extravagance
and it really left a positive impression
on the magical population
he began to receive genuine praise for
what he was doing he received an order
of merlin third class
a very prestigious award and was even
invited to join the ministry of magic
star force defence league
lockhart's old professors at hogwarts
even began to question
whether they had misjudged the confusing
young boy while he attended the school
he told book signings all over the
magical world and people loved to be
near lockhart
it was everything that he had ever
dreamt of you couldn't go anywhere
without seeing lockhart's face
or novel plus all along the insides of
shop windows
however beneath all of the charm and
fame there was actually quite a sinister
side to lockhart
it wasn't completely addressed in the
books films you see
lockhart was a memory child master and
this was one of the reasons that he had
been able to falsify
his well existence lockhart actually
wasn't a troll conqueror or dragon tamer
he was a phony
and all he did when he traveled around
the world was hear the stories of
genuinely accomplished wizards
wipe their memories then claim the
accomplishment as his own
dumbledore had lockhart to be the
hogwarts defense against the dark arts
professor for the 92-93 school year
a position that was exceedingly
difficult to fill you see we have not
been able to keep a defense against the
dark arts professor
for more than a year since i refused the
post to lord voldemort
though lockhart had been a successful
author for nearly a decade when the job
was offered to him
dumbledore knew that lockhart would
accept the role lockhart might not have
been keen to return to hogwarts
given how well his career of stolen
glory was progressing had dumbledore not
tangled the promise of harry potter over
his fame hungry head
by subtly suggesting the teaching harry
potter would set the seal on lockhart's
fame
dumbledore had set a lure that lockhart
could not resist
dumbledore also knew that lockhart was a
fraud as he personally knew two wizards
whose life's work
gilderoy lockhart had taken credit for
he was one of the only people who knew
lockhart's true nature
the dark man beneath the smile he hired
lockhart not only to expose him
but to teach students how not to be
dumbledore was convinced that lockhart
needed only to be put back into an
ordinary school setting
to be revealed as a charlatan and fraud
professor mcgonagall
who had never liked lockhart asked
dumbledore what he thought students
would learn from such a vain
fame-hungry man dumbledore replied that
there is plenty to be learned even from
a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be lockhart
happened to become a professor at the
school
in the same year the chamber of secrets
had been reopened and this was one of
the most dangerous school years
because students were dropping off left
and right to the fabled basilisk
however this couldn't have been a better
time to expose him as whenever things
got heated
lockhart was quite obviously
uncomfortable and unsure of what to do
the other professors as well as some of
the students noticed this
and he was eventually told to go to the
chamber of secrets and deal with the
monster himself
i think he was given this mission partly
so they could get him out of the way
in response to being told to go into the
chamber lockhart returned to his office
in an attempt to gather his things
before fleeing the school however it was
here that he was subsequently exposed as
a fraud
by ron and harry the boys forced
lockhart to come down into the chamber
with them
and this is where things really went
south for him hoping to take control of
the situation
lockhart grabbed ron's broken wand and
attempted to perform a memory charm on
them
the adventure ends here boys i shall
take a bit of this skin
back up to the school tell them i was
too late to save the girl
and that you two tragically lost your
mind at the sight of a mangled body
say goodbye to your memories obliviate
however
given that the wand was well broken it
backfired on lockhart instead
the faulty wand sent him flying into a
pile of rubble and subsequently caused
him to lose all of his memories
complete amnesia he was no longer the
brave troll conqueror and dragon tamer
in fact he didn't know who he was after
harriet finished in the chamber of
secrets
lockhart was saved by forks and walked
up mcgonagall's office
it was here that it became apparent to
staff and students alike the lockhart
completely lost his marbles
and dumbledore instructed ron to take
him to the hospital wing
after careful inspection it was decided
that dockhart wouldn't be able to
operate in society
in the state that he was in and he was
subsequently sent to the jainus thickey
ward
in saint mungo's hospital for magical
maladies a ward dedicated
to those suffering from permanent spell
damage lockhart remained there for many
years
and he's briefly mentioned again in the
following passage from the order of the
phoenix
but as he stepped onto the landing he
came to an abrupt halt
staring at the small window set into the
double doors and marked the start of a
corridor signposted
spell damage a man was peering out at
the mall with his nose pressed against
the glass
he had wavy blonde hair bright blue eyes
and a broad vacant smile
that revealed dazzlingly white teeth it
has been expressed that dumbledore never
exposed lockhart for his crimes after
being sent to saint mangos
and even though lockhart had stolen the
glory of many dumbledore felt that
lockhart's fate was already bad enough
that there was no reason to further step
on an already down drop
man by exposing him the only result
would be hate and contempt towards a man
that knew nothing of what he had done
lockhart paid his dues by losing his
memory
and his life because lockhart had never
been exposed he was allowed to write
again
and subsequently continued his path as
an author once he had recovered
somewhat writing the book who am i with
the help of the staff of saint mungos
during christmas in 1995 harry ron
hermione and ginny
saw like heart in janus sticky ward and
despite the total loss of his memory
he seemed just as lockhart as ever
offering up autographs and the like
he'd regained just enough memory to
remember writing in cursive
teach me did i taught you everything you
know
expect did i well how about those
autographs then shall we say
around dozen you can give them to all
your little friends then and nobody will
be left out
sadly lockhart never got many visitors
but he still got fan mail from a witch
named gladys gudjin
and developed a close relationship with
his carer miriam strout
though lockhart never made a full
recovery he did sign autographs the rest
of his days
and it has been expressed that he was
happier that way blissfully ignorant
but more than happy to reap the benefits
of his illustrious fame
to this day no one knows if he ever
properly left saint mangos
and that's it for this video did you
guys ever wonder what happened to
lockhart
do you think he eventually left saint
margo's let me know in the comment
section
below until next time remember there is
plenty to be learned even from a bad
teacher
what not to do how not to be
you